ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الثاني دقائق
طويله امضاها دونالد ترامب في جلسه محاكمه
تاريخيه امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي
بسلاح التحدي وباصرار على البراءه واجه
ترامب العداله ونفرتكابه اي مخالفات في
قضيه مطارده الساحرات بحسب وصفه انتهت
الجلسه وخرج ترامب وبدا عاصفته هجومه على
الجهاز القضائي الامريكي مؤكدا انه ضحيه
وزاره العدل التي اتهمها بالفساد واعتبر
محكمته اسوا استغلال شرير وشنيع للسلطه في
تاريخ امريكا ترامب يمتلك الحق في مواجهه
المحكمه في غضون 100 يوم ولكن
قضيته من المرجح ان توافق الاطراف المعنيه
على تمديد المواعيد النهائيه هذا متوقع
وفق مراقبين رغم تاكيد سابق للموضع
الفيدرا
بان ترامب سيحظى بمحاكمه سريعه ويرجح
او يرجح ومداد المحاكمه لاشهر ان يصدم
بموعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه بل
وربما بفوز ترامب في تلك الحاله يرجح
العديد من القانونيين عدم استمرار
المحاكمه اذا دخل رئيس السابق مجددا الى
البيت الابيض لا سيما ان وزاره العدل
تعتبر جزءا وتعتبر جزء من السلطه
التنفيذيه ثم رؤساءهم على سلطه انسات
القوانين الفيدراليه في البلاد
[تصفيق]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
بشر جرار الكاتب المحلل السياسي اهلا بك
ومن احمد الحنطي الباحث في الشان الامريكي
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان نبدا
بسؤال مباشر
لكما الاثنين ولكن قبل ذلك سنتابع بعضا من
التصريحات التي ستكون في صلب النقاط التي
سنناقشها ونعود من جديد
[موسيقى]
اليوم شهدنا اكثر نهار فيه شر في تاريخ
بلادنا لم نرى يوما رئيسا سابقا يتعرض على
يد خصومه لما عشته اليوم كل هذا في خضام
الانتخابات والسباق الرئاسي هذا ما يسمى
بالتدخل في الانتخابات من اجل سرقتها
والاهم من ذلك انه اضطهاد سياسي واضح وهو
من خصال الدول الفاشيه والشيوعيه سنتذكر
هذا اليوم وسنتذكر ان الرئيس بايدن هو
الاكثر فسادا وهو محاط بزمره من الاشخاص
تسعى لقتل الديموق الامريكيه لكنهم
سيفشلون وسنفوز في النهايه
الى ضيوف واسمحوا لي ان ابدا منه استاذ
احمد
بالعامله ما حدث بالامس هل ما حدث هل
تصريحات ترامب هل
ما قيل حول هذه المحاكمه سيستفيد منها
ترامب في الانتخابات الحزبيه وان اكمل
المشوار في الانتخابات الوطنيه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بك
ما طرحه ترامب في خطاب البارحه ليس جديدا
يعني هذه الافكار وهذه الهجوم هو يطرحه من
فتره يعني منذ ان بدا الحديث عن فتح
التحقيق
لا اعتقد ان الاثر سيكون كبيرا ولكنه لن
يكون ايجابي بمعنى هناك فئه
يعني من من يميلون لمرشحين اخرين اليوم
سيفكرون بانه بما ان الادعاء الان يهاجم
ترامب بالتالي هم يخشون يخشون من فوزه
لانه يعني هو المنافس الاقوى فبالتالي
سيبينون لنا ولكن هناك فئه اخرى ايضا
ستفكر بانه
اذا كانت ربي يعني يتعرض لمحاكمات الان
ومحاكمات خطيره وتهم جديه بالتالي فرصته
في الفوز بالانتخابات العامه ستكون اضعف
وهذا يعني يجعلهم يميلون الى اختيار مرشح
اخر للحزب ربما تكون فرصته اقوى في هزيمه
بايدن الاستاذ بشار هل يمكن فعلا كما يقول
استاذ احمد ان يتراجع البعض في دعم ترامب
في دعم ترامب من بعد هذه المحاكمه ومن بعد
طبعا اللائحه الاتهامات
جدا لان ما جرى في تفاصيل الملاحقات
المتلاحقه التي تعرض لها مرشحا ب 2016
وحتى الان يظهر ان هذا الموضوع يستقطب
المزيد من القوى التي تسببت بانقسام
امريكا وتزيد من هذه بتعمق هذا الشرخ الكل
الان يفهم الرساله المشكله ليست كما قيل
في مواجهات سابقه بانها تتعلق بشخصيه
ترامب او بطريقه ادارته السياسيه او حتى
كثير للاداره الامريكيه لا ابدا تبين الان
وبشكل قطعي ان المشكله هي ما الذي يصطدم
معه ترامب وقد اكتسبت مقوله انه يواجه
الدوله العميقه ومستنقع واشنطن تبين انها
لم تكن شعارات هكذا غلاميه ان نعم عندما
قال مثلا بان الاعلام هو
عدول الامه الامريكيه الكل صد ونحن
العالمين وجه خاص ضمنا ماذا تقول الصحافه
الامريكيه هذه التي بدات الدنيا وتعلمنا
في مدرستها اصبحت عدوا الامه الامريكيه
اجواب نعم الان الان قطعا الصحافه في
امريكا
اصبحت على دول الامم الامريكيه اصبحت عدوا
للاسر الامريكيه الاسر التي قامت على قيام
امريكا بقواعد الاباء المؤسسين اصبحت
الاسر العربيه لاسر المسلمه المسيحيه
اليهوديه بذلك رايت امس في هضانه الصغيره
رايت كيف قسيس وحاخام يصلون في مطعم يملك
كوبيون مهاجرون قدامى لا يريدون ان تتحول
بهذه الجمله الشيوعيه فالان نعم انا لاول
مره اقر بذلك وعليتا انا كنت من الذين
يفكر جديا باختيار بديل عن ترامب الان
قطعا لا لان الان الانقسام الذي حصل في
القاعده الشعبيه الامريكيه يظهر من يهادم
هذه القوه التي تعاد ترامب ستكون فيه
مشكله
ولكن استاذ بشار ان كنت حضرتك انت طرحت
السؤال ومرت على ذهنك بعض الشكوك في موضوع
دعم تراب من غيره وانا اعلم طبعا من خلال
حضورك معنا مدى دعمك خلال كل هذه السنوات
فالاقل دعما من حضرتك قادر ان يغير موقفه
من ترامب يعني الكلام اللي طرحه استاذ
احمد دقيق هناك البعض راجع حساباته بعد
لائحه الاتهامات هذه
دقيق ولكن لا اقول ايضا اكون صريح معك كنت
يعني اتلمس
الذي كان مديرا وكان وزيرا خارجيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نعم
الحلفاء في الشرق الاوسط كانت تستقيم مع
ماء انا كاميركي من اصل عربي كجمهور محافظ
ولكن عندما وقف الى جانب الدوله العميقه
في مقوله وكذبه الاعلام بانه يعني يكاد
يكون جاسوس
هذه مشكله كبيره معناها المشكله الان ايضا
ليس هذا وقته ديسانتس قطعا سننتخب بعد
ولايه الترامب المقبله ولكن على المستوى
الحزبي روندا
مدعوم استاذ احمد كبار المنيحين في
الحزباء الجمهوري لا زالوا يدعمون ديسانتس
هل تعتقد بان ترامب سيبقى شخصيه الابرز
والاكبر داخل الحزب الجمهوري ام ان هناك
اسم ثاني قد يزاحمه على هذه المرتبه
الاولى
حتى الان لا يوجد اسم قادر على مزاحمه انا
اعتقد على على يعني رغم انه الاكثر حظوظا
حتى الان يعني بعد ترامب الا انه لن
يستطيع الفوز ربما ربما
قد قد يستطيع جذب يعني نسبه تاييد ولكن
هذا الامر ليس مؤكد هذا الامر مشكوك فيه
ما لم يتغير ما لم يحدث تغيير كبير سيكون
هو مرشح الحزب كل المرشحين الحاليين اضعف
من ان يستطيعوا هزيمته وحتى سياساتهم يعني
سياساتهم الانتخابيه طريقه مخاطبتهم
للجمهور ليست ناجحه بما يكفي للجذب تاييد
يفوق التاييد الذي لا تتربه ولكن لماذا قد
يكون ترامب المسيطر الوحيد على الحزب
الجمهوري استاذ احمد لانه يسيطر فعليا
لازال يتحكم في
داخل الحزب الجمهوري او لان هناك دعم
ايمان به كشخصيه قادره ان تنافس
الديمقراطي في مراحل متقدمه
الجمهوريين ينقسمون الى ثلاث اقسام القسم
الاول هي القاعده الصلبه لترامب هالو
هؤلاء لا يرون الترام بديلا ولا يمكن ان
يصوتوا لعي مرشح اخر ما دام اسم ترامب
موجود الفئه الثانيه هم من ليس لديهم
اعتراض على ترامب هم يرون انه كان رئيس
جيد وكان
ادى فترته ولكنهم يميلون بعض الشيء الى
فتح صفحه جديده مع اسم جديد وتوجهات جديده
هذه الفئه هي الان المنقسمه ما بين ترامب
وما بين المرشحين الاخرين الفئه الثالثه
وهي فئه الرافدين للترامب والذين مستعدين
لقبول اي اسم اخر مشكله جميع المرشحين
الموجودين في الساحه الان انهم يحاولون
استقطاب قاعده ترامب قاعده ترامب لا يمكن
ان تتخلى عنه ومخاطبه هذه القاعده ومحاوله
اجتذابها تنثر الفئتين الاخرين من المرشح
لذلك لا يوجد احد قادر على تحقيق المعادله
اللازمه لهزيمه ترامب في
انتخابات الاوليه
استاذ جرار هل تعتقد بانه تصريحات بعض
الجمهورين ومن بينهم مرشحون كذلك نتحدث عن
هاي لنتحدث على على
هل باعتقادك بانه لا لن اتحدث عن ان كنت
تؤمن بترشحها وبفوزه بالانتخابات ساتحدث
عن تصريحات في خصوص محاكمات ترامب لانه
بعضهم التزم الصمت في مرحله اولى وبعضهم
كان متردد في محاوله تقديمه لموقف من هذه
المحاكمه هل تعتقد بان هذا الجو العام قد
يخلق ازمه داخل الحزب الجمهوري
سؤال جميل
والاجابات ساخذها ليس فقط من المرشحين
ساعيدك ايضا الى الرموز القويه جدا في
الحزب الجمهوري وعلى راسها طبعا مش باكال
زعيم الاقليه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه
الذي يؤثر ويقول مرارا بانه يريد ان يبتعد
عن مواجهه ترامب لانه يعلم انه لن يبقى في
منصبه في حال عوده ترامب ايضا شخصيه مهمه
ولافته هي متمثله في الانستقرام هذا
السيناتور المخضرم الذي شهدنا كيف تبرئ من
ترامب في احداث سته يناير وقام بتوبيخه
علانيه فهو يعود الان ويتخذ موقفا متشددا
حتى بالاي بي سي النيوز المقابله التي تم
يعني اشار اليه كمثال ان الجمهوريون
الجمهوريين الان
بداوا يعني يكونون عدائيين الى حد ما او
هجوميين حتى ما وس
نصبها ترامب قبل ثلاث سنوات وهناك حتى من
تحدث عن امكانيه ان تستخدم هذه تكلمت عنها
في خصوص التوقيتات في خصوص المدد الزمنيه
دون ان تخرج على اطار القانون ولكن هذه
المده الزمنيه ستمكن ترامب وفريقه الدفاع
كذلك من محاوله ايجاد حلول وهنا سؤال
استاذ احمد الوقت في صالح من هل هو في
صالح ترامب او ضده لانه نحن نتحدث عن خوض
انتخابات حزبيه وخوض انتخابات وطنيه قادمه
وراء القطبان مثلا
ابدا هذا لن يحصل لان حتى المدعي العام
السيد السميث هو قال انه اريد محاكمه
عاجله لانه متهم القبريئا الان موضوع مجرد
خبر احدى المحطات الامريكيه لا اريد ان
ادخل ببعض تفاصيل لاسباب معينه عندما قالت
ترامب رهن الاعتقاله انا تلقيت بعض
الاسئله من اصدقاء داخل الولايات المتحده
وخارجها انه هل بالفعل ترامب الان يعني
بالاصفاظ وطبعا هذا كله المقصود منه هو
الاثاره ونوع من الترويع النفسي يعني
هؤلاء الممولين ولكن الممول الذي يضع
بالملايين استثمارات في قضايا تتعلق في
الحملات الانتخابيه لن تاخذها هذه الاخبار
وسر نجاح ترامب مع كل محاكمه سواء حاليا
او في نيويورك كان دائما ما هو ارقام غير
مسبوقه بمتبرعين جدد وبصغار المتبرعين
نتحدث عن 20 نعم هذا يشير الى اي خصم
يواجهون الان ترامب عشرين اخطر من ترامب
2016 و2020 استاذ احمد يبقى سؤال شعبيا
هذه القضايا هذا النوع من القضايا ان كانت
القضايا الاخلاقيه التي تبعنا محاكمه
ترامب بخصوصها منذ شهرين او هذا النوع من
المحاكمات والخاص بالامن القومي الامريكي
هل ينفر منه الشارع الامريكي او بالعكس
يتابعه ويرى في المتهم بانه صار صاحب راي
صاحب قضيه يدافع عن نفسه
مستهدف من مجموعه اشرار كما قلت ترامب
ليس ليس فئه واحده وليس عقليه واحده هناك
فئات مختلفه وكل فئات تنظر للامر من
زاويتها الخاصه ولكن ما يهمنا هنا هو
الاجمالي لو عدنا الاستطلاعات الرئيس سنجد
انه يعني قبل قبل اسابيع يمكن شهرين او
يقابل ما يقارب ذلك عندما كانت
الاستطلاعات تشير الى ان يعني نسبه من
يرون ان القضيه هذه جديه فعلا ارتفع
ارتفعت اليوم يعني بما لا يقل عن 20 نقطه
هذا ارتفاع كبير بخصوصا بين المستقلين
والمستقلين عاده هم من يرجح من يفوز في
الانتخابات بالتالي هي لن تكون مفيده
للترمب لن تساعده على الفوز قد يفوز ترب
الرغم من القضيه ولكنه لن يفوز بسبب
القضيه كيف ترى نفس هذا الموضوع
انا اعتقد انه بمجرد انه ننتبه جميع
للاعلام يعني نتحدث جميع الاقتربين من
الواسطه الاعلامي انظر الى هذه الحمله
الانتخابيه يصورونه وهو بالموكب الموتوركي
وكل الوقفات بالطائره كل شيء يتحدث به حتى
مذيع السينان امس يعني بالخطا ذكرت اسم
الشبكه
اي اخبار واي صحافه هذه اذا ترام كلمته
امس يعني الف باء الاعلام انت تلحق الحدث
وكانوا يبثون كلمات ارهابيين على الهواء
مباشره مترجمه وباللغات فانت تتسائلي
سيدتي هل ترامب هو الذي يمتلك النار
الشركه العام بيده شاؤا وبصرف النظر ولكن
خليني اختم بسؤال نعم ام لا فقط لانه فقط
لنا عشر ثواني هل يمكن ان يكون ترامب رئيس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه القادم
مستجرار نعم ام لا نعم استاذ احمد فقط اذا
تم ابتزازه الوقت استاذ احمد
نعم
غير قادر واضح
شكرا جزيلا لكم على المشاركه وكل ما
تفضلتم به باشا جرار الكاتب المحلى
السياسي واحمد الحمصي الباحث في شان
الامريكي شكرا لكم على المتابعه والسلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات